digital marketing tools are essential
Assets in the modern marketing landscape
these software Solutions and platforms
Empower businesses and marketers to plan
execute analyze and optimize their
online marketing strategies from search
engine optimization and social media
management to email marketing analytics
and content creation these tools
streamline processes enhance efficiency
and drive better results in the digital
realm in this digital age leveraging the
right marketing tools is the key to
staying competitive and achieving
marketing objectives effectively so if
you are looking to become a digital
marketing specialist and learn all the
essential digital marketing tools then
look no further than simply learns
post-graduate program in digital
marketing with this you will gain all
the necessary skills in digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more so if you are
looking to become a digital marketing
specialist and learn all the essential
digital marketing tools then look no
further then simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing with this
you gain all the necessary skills in
digital marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more with knowledge
of tools like SE ranking Hood suit chat
GPT Google ads Google Keyword Planner
Google Trends and there's much more on
the list don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity as only one year
of experience is preferred to enroll in
this course take action today and enroll
in a course to unlock the digital
marketing success accelerate your career
and gain the skills you need to thrive
in the industry ready to get started
click the link in the description box
and embark on your journey to
professional growth and achievement
without any further Ado let's begin the
number one tool in our list is Google
analytics website tracking plays an
important role in digital marketing it
helps in understanding the user behavior
on your website do you know that there
are around 38 million websites that use
Google analytics including Airbnb Uber
Spotify and udmi analytics is an
analytics tools used for tracking a
website the standard version of Google
analytics is free we can integrate
Google analytics with Google ads as well
the key features of Google analytics
include tracking website traffic user
demographics page views bounce rates
conversion rates and much more with
these valuable insights businesses can
optimize the digital strategies improve
user experience and ultimately boost on
online performance towards the next tool
which is Google ads Google ads is a
vital tool in digital marketing it lets
businesses display the ads on Google
search results and partner sites key
features include keyword targeting
budget control audience targeting and
robust analytics advertisers can
optimize ads for mobile conduct AB
testing and benefit from the features
like remarketing and AD extensions it's
a versatile tool for reaching the Right
audience at the right time driving
traffic and boosting conversions in the
competitive online landcape on number
three we have Google search console
Google search console is a free web
master tool provided by Google it is
important to timely monitor your website
and make it error free this is where
Google search console comes into the
picture it helps businesses to Monitor
and maintain their websites present in
Google search result some features of
Google Search consult includes getting
confirmation that the Google search
engine can crawl your website fix the
problems in the page indexing sense page
for reindexing can view Google search
traffic data record the number of times
your website appears in the search
results records the search engine
queries for which your websites appears
in the search results show the list of
sites linking to you and many more on
number four we have Sam rush to grow
your business it is essential to keep an
eye on what your competitors are doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis Sim Rush is a competitor
analysis tools that gives a complete
work through of the competitor's data
like keywords backlinks top performing
content campaigns Etc it has free as
well as paid versions on number five we
have MailChimp MailChimp is a popular
email marketing platform known for its
userfriendly interface it offers
features like email campaign creation
marketing automation audience
segmentation analytics and integration
with other tools it's widely used for
engaging with audiences and nurturing
leads through the personalized email
marketing on number six we have canva
canva is a userfriendly graphic design
tool that empowers digital marketers to
create eye-catching visuals for social
media email marketing ads INF graphics
and more it helps to maintain Brad
consistency enhance content engagement
and simplifies the design process making
it a valuable asset in digital marketing
efforts next we have is HubSpot HubSpot
is all-in-one digital marketing and
sales platform known for its inbound
marketing strategies it provides tools
for Content creation automation CRM
analytics and more hubs sport helps
businesses attract engage hubs sport
helps businesses to attract engage and
convert leads into customers by
streamlining marketing and sales efforts
on number eight we have ah revs gaining
high quality backlink is an essential
factor in digital marketing and SEO
ranking as it shows the trust of other
website in your content moreover it
helps in building the authority of your
website ahrs is a comprehensive SE
toolkit that includes features like
backlink analysis key research site
Audits and competitor analysis it's
valuable tool for improving website
performance and achieving better search
engine rankings the next tool on the
list we have is grammarly grammarly is a
vital tool in digital marketing ensuring
error free engaging content across the
channel it enhances quality SE
optimization and consistency time saving
and improving audience engagement in
email social media and content creation
last but not least we have moss moss is
a key player in digital marketing
specializing Ino tools and resources it
helps marketers with keyword research
backlink analysis onpage SEO local SEO
content strategies and Technical SEO MOS
also offers educational content and
supportive Community to stay updated
with SEO best practices and Industry
Trends so before we end this video
listen to what our Learners say about
our courses so here we wrap up top 10
digital marketing tools for 2024 if you
like this video share it with your
friends and don't forget to subscribe to
Simply learn for more updates thanks for
watching staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here